[Musica]
allora questa questo titolo perché si
devono amare i bambini non c'è un punto
interrogativo perché si devono amare i
bambini potevo dire si devono ascoltare
si devono capire se devono rispettare ci
dobbiamo credere nei bambini e il potere
del contatto e dell'ossitocina in che
senso contatto nel senso che nella
nostra cultura abbiamo bisogno di un
grosso cambiamento anche prima abbiamo
parlato di cambiamento il cambiamento
tante volte spaventa come nel parto non
ci si prepara al parto vedono
protonotario cioè si possono fare tante
cose conoscere tante cose però nessuno
sa prima come sarà il suo parto perché
si vive perché le emozioni si vivono e
la vita con i nostri bambini si vive
quelli che abbiamo magari sono proprio
nostri l'abbiamo generati ma anche
quelli che incontriamo anche i bambini
che eravamo quindi perché il contatto il
contatto è un qualcosa che nella nostra
cultura italiana ma soprattutto
occidentale viene considerato un vizio
quindi il bambino troppo in braccio il
bambino che dorme vicino ai genitori
addirittura nello stesso letto che sta
attaccato troppo al seno è un bambino
viziato figlio di genitori non sono in
grado di dargli le regole allora noi
abbiamo bisogno di un cambiamento
abbiamo bisogno di un cambiamento che
rispetti i bisogni e i sentimenti non
solo dei bambini ma delle persone
noi ma oggi siamo a un teteks quindi io
ho un'idea innovativa ma l'idea
innovativa secondo me anche molto banale
è quella di credere ognuno e noi stessi
e di mettere al centro le persone a
qualsiasi sanno le professioni
io sono una psicologa ho scritto tre
libri sto scrivendo il quarto ma mi
ritengo un mezzo un mezzo per la
conoscenza in questo caso della
fisiologia c'è anche tanto altro ma di
fisiologia si parla poco e per questo vi
racconto due minuti della mia storia
io a tre anni dissi a mia madre poi
magari mi commuovo disse a mia madre che
avrei voluto lavorare con i neonati e
proprio percepivo c'è la voglia di stare
insieme neonati perché mi sono sempre
piaciuti tantissimo
qui in sala c'è una signora che conosco
molto bene che mi ha detto di essere
diventata nonna 52 anni io ne ho 50 ho
detto mamma ho due figli una ri 14 una
di 10 quanto mi ci vuole ancora no
tantissimo di sicuro quindi e dopo di
questo è successo io ho fatto nelle
vent'anni ho fatto rimedio fatto liceo
scientifico su pure bocciato l'anno ma
sono finalmente arrivata a medicina
perché volevo fare la neonatologa poi
però non mi potevo mantenere agli studi
dovevo lavorare
e allora facendo la baby sitter e
imparando tantissimo dai bambini e dalle
mamme col quale ho avuto l'onore di
lavorare
sono passata psicologia a roma facendo
delle corse incredibili prendendo il
treno la mattina alle 7 andando a dare
l'esame e poi alle quattro andando a
prendere i bambini a scuola e quindi
sono arrivata a poi avere questa
benedetta laurea in psicologia
dell'educazione e dello sviluppo
volendo però fare qualcosa di diverso da
quello che avevo studiato quindi ho
detto ma sarà giusto quello che ho fatto
perché mi interessavano ancora i neonati
e io di non ha finora con studiato
niente alla mia facoltà non avevo
studiato l'allattamento nei vostri la
sua il sonno
e allora che cosa è successo è successo
che ho pensato proprio che ci voleva un
grosso cambiamento un cambiamento dovuto
a anche la mia esperienza a quel punto
di studi ma non solo un cambiamento
sulla carta un cambiamento proprio di
trasformazione di processo tante volte
si pensa di dover imparare un metodo
nuovo per cambiare anche quando siamo
genitori
in realtà bisogna guardarsi dentro molto
spesso il cambiamento nasce proprio da
dentro di noi e quindi quando sono nate
ste due gli arriva la commissione prix
la prima soprattutto questo dovrebbe
essere un puntatore ma non funziona la
quella di destra che si chiama bianca è
arrivato il mio vero tsunami non mi è
servito nulla di quello che avevo fatto
giuro perché è arrivata è arrivato
l'amore è arrivato un qualcosa di
travolgente sono è arrivato il doversi è
dover essere h 24 7 giorni su 7 365
giorni alla settimana 365 giorni l'anno
a disposizione essere chiamata in
qualsiasi momento del giorno e della
notte
un amore incredibile che però tante
volte c'è anche tanti ambivalenze chi di
noi mamme e mamma in questa sala la sera
sa che molto spesso non siamo riusciti a
farci una non l'avevamo concordato prima
funziona
sempre e dice ma le mamme sono tutte
zone scusate il termine toscano no no è
che mettiamo sempre prima loro sempre
perché questo vuol dire amarli no però
tante volte ci dimentichiamo quelli che
sono i nostri bisogni di mamme di
persone e tendiamo a voler considerare
loro ma attendiamo anche a sentire tutto
quello che ci dicono intorno e quindi
questo può creare un pochino di
confusione quindi dopo che è nato
appunto la mia bambina sono passati tre
anni la bambina non dormiva a me non mi
avevano detto nulla che potevano esserci
risvegli notturni e io ho cominciato a
studiare il sonno
mia madre mi diceva la bambina ma hai
pianto il primo mese la notte da sola
nella sua collina poi non hai pianto più
e allora io adesso studio sono infantile
e lo porto in giro per l'italia
ecco forse che sta a un senso allora non
aver pianto che il mese del mio primo
mese di vita o posso ho scoperto un
sacco di cose sul sogno infantile in
italia però è un po scomodo dire perché
quando portiamo un'idea nuova un area e
va controcorrente siamo scomodi vedo
questa bruttissima notizia ma essere qui
fa sì che abbia un senso anche questo
perché vuol dire che certe volte la
scomodità interessa interessa chi
organizza interessa chi è venuto e
sinceramente ormai io ci credo proprio e
perché siamo scomodi perché chiediamo
appunto un cambiamento ma chiediamo una
cosa ancora più profonda la seconda
bimba si chiama irene bisogna dirlo ecco
il cambiamento più profondo entra in
contatto con questa bambina qui che la
bambina che sono stata e che ognuno di
voi ha dentro di voi il bambino che è
stato perché quando nascono i nostri
bambini ci riportano alla memoria
molto spesso la memoria affettiva non è
una memoria molto spesso cosciente ci
riportano i vissuti abbiamo vissuto
scusate il gioco di parole e questo non
è facile perché molto spesso ci
intortano scusate il termine con dei
metodi cioè che devi imparare che il
bambino dorme la notte sete usi questo
metodo ma i bambini hanno bisogno di
svegliarsi fino a circa tre anni
altra brutta notizia che sta dando un
sacco di brutte notizie ma questo
qualcuno lo deve dire e non solo solo io
per carità ci sono tantissime persone
che adesso finalmente diffondono queste
cose ma se una mamma quando diventa
mamma un papa una famiglia non è entrato
in contatto con queste informazioni poi
pensa di essere sbagliata cioè è
sbagliata lei ho sbagliato il suo
bambino
e allora cosa nasce nasce il senso di
colpa che è una di quelle cose terribili
che più più o meno tutti proviamo della
nostra vita che è l'altra faccia della
rabbia la rabbia di solito è diretta
verso l'esterno il senso di colpa è
diretto verso l'esterno ma è la stessa
cosa
ecco quindi entrare in contatto con i
bambini che siamo stati significa capire
meglio anche i bambini che incontreremo
non solo se li abbiamo generati
e allora cosa succede succede che io vi
racconto questa altra piccola cosa a mio
padre che forse chissà un giorno vedrà
sto video mi definiva fin da bambina
alice nel paese delle meraviglie e io
l'ho pensata come una cosa tremenda cioè
tutto quello in cui io credevo che un
giorno avrei lavorato con lasi che un
giorno sarei stata sicuramente una mamma
in gamba perché speravo di poterlo
essere io ero in sicura perché se mio
padre mi diceva che io ero alice nel
paese delle meraviglie
porca miseria allora forse avevo un
problema e negli anni questa cosa poi
via via me la sono portata dietro quindi
quando qualcuno di voi pensava di avere
un'idea strana a cui nessuno crede
proponi lo spirito ed io voglio dire
crederci fino in fondo perché quando
prendevo quei treni per andare a roma
per fare gli esami
magari prendevo se lenta ma non sapevo
manco chi fossero i professori
io ci ho sempre creduto e quindi questo
è anche il messaggio che vi voglio
mandare non sempre quando si pensa una
cosa strana che va controcorrente quando
segniamo un bambino in braccio e tutti
ci dicono ma bastano ammettilo giù è
furbo ma perché abbiamo così poca
fiducia nei bambini
questa è una domanda io non ho mai
trovato una risposta perché abbiamo così
poca fiducia in quello che loro ci
comunicano si parla tanto di empatia ci
sono i corsi ci sono i coach e cioè quel
che c'è di tutto sull'empatia ma ci
siamo persi di vista una cosa è
l'empatia vuol dire il qui e ora non
vuol dire io capisco cosa dici te o te
e allora ok sono d'accordo no vuol dire
io mi spoglio dei giudici
io sospendo il giudizio io mi metto in
gioco col cuore e cerco di far
comunicare i nostri cuori e questo i
bambini sono rimastre a insegnarcelo i
bambini sono l'occasione strepitosa per
cos'è linko entrare in contatto con i
nostri cuori anche attraverso la
relazione nella parola magica affettiva
e creiamo con loro però nella nostra
cultura ci viene detto no il bambino
bravo è quello che sta da solo il prima
possibile dorme tutta la notte il
genitore bravo e quello che glielo
insegna però tutto questo non trova
supporto della scienza
e allora come come si fa si fa che noi
dobbiamo cominciare a pensare in termini
di norba biologica ma è di norma
culturale cioè la normalità culturale
della nostra cultura è il bambino di
spaccato il prima possibile dal corpo ed
alle braccia di chi si prende cura di
lui
e mentre la norma la norma biologica
cioè come siamo fatti il fatto io alla
gamba destra o alla gamba sinistra non
può parlare solo di una senza parlare
dell'altra direbbe che invece il
contatto è proprio un bisogno primario
posso dire un nome su tutti john bowlby
john bowlby è stato il padre della serie
dell'attaccamento uno psicologo di tanti
anni fa psicoanalista e lui dichiarò
intorno agli anni sessanta del secolo
scorso che l'attaccamento il bisogno
proprio di attaccamento quindi di
relazione era primario con per questo
motivo lui fu radiato dalla società
africana lisina era alice nel paese
delle meraviglie basta devi andare via
sulla sua tomba nel 1990 ha fatto
scrivere qui giace lo psicanalista
perché lui sapeva cosa stava dicendo e
dovete sapere che john bowlby ha scritto
anche tanto sul sogno condiviso c'è sola
possibilità di dormire vicino ai bambini
eppure italiano queste cose non sono
tradotti perché la barriera culturale
noi abbiamo la barriera incredibile cioè
non arrivano ai genitori di un certo
tipo di cultura alcune informazioni
quindi noi noi dico di qua abbiamo il
dovere di essere un mezzo per questa
informazione
allora i bisogni sono la chiave la
relazione affettiva sono la chiave ma
mio figlio in questo momento di cosa
bisogna cosa mi sta comunicando quando
io arrivai genitori max e di cosa ha
bisogno ma io sono venuto da lei melo
lei no il figlio e tu sei sua madre tu
sicuramente sai di più di me di cosa ha
bisogno di posso dire come funziona il
suo sonno posso valutare se è un
disturbo del sonno ma non so in questo
preciso momento di cosa ha bisogno tuo
figlio e le mamme di solito i papà le
saliranno i bisogni dei loro bambini ma
si sentono giudicati quindi ci saranno
dei momenti in cui prevarrà il distacco
pensate alla nascita è il primo grande
distacco che ognuno di noi ha
sperimentato nella propria vita non si
esce dal nero materno si esce da un
mondo protetto per entrare in una
miriade di stimoli e anche che sono
molto difficile da decodificare per un
neonato ecco e agli in altri momenti
prepara alla norma biologica fino a tre
anni noi sappiamo che l'esigenza di
contatto è un'esigenza primaria quindi
la dobbiamo rispettare
allora noi abbiamo bisogno di rispettare
le emozioni sono connesse a questi
bisogni ma non solo le emozioni dei
bambini ma anche le emozioni delle mamme
perché non si parla mai delle emozioni
delle mamme si parla sempre si diventa
mamme non si fa la doccia ma non ci si
ascolta tante volte e questo significa
che noi superiamo il nostro limite cioè
quello oltre 2 non dovremmo andare
perché sennò poi rischiavo di
arrabbiarci con i nostri bambini perché
loro loro sono bambini non devono essere
adulti ci deve essere un confine tra ciò
che è loro e ciò che è nostro
quindi anche le emozioni delle mamme
sono importanti non abbiate paura se
provate rabbia se provate senso di colpa
se provate tristezza è importante che
queste emozioni possano venire fuori
tutte le emozioni sono importanti
dobbiamo essere autentici questa è
l'altra parola assolutamente che voglio
portarvi oggi perché molto spesso noi
diciamo sì sì ce la facciano no ma ce la
faccio se si va benissimo ma non è vero
niente
e i nostri bambini se come prediligono
più piccoli che solo la comunicazione
non verbale lo capiscono subito se c'è
qualcosa che non va quindi c'è
un'ambivalenza poi fra quello che noi
comunichiamo a livello verbale e quello
che loro vedono e tante volte sono hanno
bisogno di autenticità a loro come
abbiamo bisogno di semplicità noi di
poter dire sono stanca voglio fare una
doccia
allora proprio in conclusione
noi abbiamo due sistemi che c
proprio dirigono il corpo che è il
sistema dell'attacco e fuga quello
dell'adrenalina quello della difesa
quello che ci fa scappare quando c'è un
pericolo e tutti lo conosciamo ma
abbiamo anche un altro sistema è quello
della calma della connessione quello
della ricompensa quello del piacere
secondo voi gli studi scientifici in che
proporzione li esplorano questi studi
provate a sparare un numero innanzitutto
quale di più secondo voi nella nostra
società che va di fretta che corre che
mira sulla competizione non sulla
cooperazione quella dell'attacco in fuga
sapete in quale percentuale nel 90 per
cento è stata fatta una meta analisi da
questa autrice testi novas muover lei è
una studiosa gli studi all'ossitocina e
lo stesso cina è una sostanza che tutti
noi uomini donne bambini e mettiamo e
produciamo per la ricerca del benessere
della calma della connessione della
ricompensa questa studioso e la studiosa
numero uno mondiale sugli effetti
comportamentali dell'ossitocina cioè su
come noi la possiamo ricercare nella
vita di tutti i giorni adesso facciamo
un piccolo giochino questo è solo
l'ultimo avvisando svegli 30 secondi
riabbraccio abbracciatevi abbracciatevi
alzate mi fate quello che volete
rimanete come volete rimanete
abbracciati cosa è successo
cosa è successo poi cosa è successo
stiamo bene allora ho solo due minuti e
53 allora questa signora ha scritto 400
articoli sullo su come procurarsi losito
cina e non è una droga una roba come
vedete a disposizione di tutti
anche qui in questo momento tre libri
meravigliosi neanche uno di questi
articoli e tradotto in italiano neanche
uno di questi libri ciò significa di
nuovo nella nostra cultura
noi non sappiamo come procurarci il
piacere in maniera semplice così come
avete provato ora voi
con questo semplice abbraccio soli 30
secondi io sono diventata rossa perché
proprio mi sento bollire qualcuno che
voleva era sentito anche dai messaggi
del proprio corpo quindi noi possiamo
fare questo possiamo coltivare anche
quell'altro sistema che deve essere il
bilanciamento con quello dell'adrenalina
della calma e della connessione l'ormone
dell'amore lo chiamano lo stesso chino
mano muore in senso estremamente ampio
perché mettere al mondo e curare anche a
livello educativo dei bambini che
sapranno che cosa vuol dire anche poter
attingere alle proprie emozioni
significa non ce lo dice l'epigenetica
non solo investire su di loro ma
significa investire anche sui loro figli
perché questo tipo di approccio passa le
generazioni ma non è facile se non lo
abbiamo avuto ricordate la bambina che è
in noi e cioè più solo proprio degli
studi che ci dicono che è difficile
cambiare il modello educativo col quale
siamo stati educati e propormi un altro
ai nostri figli
e questa è l'ultima diapositiva chi
ascolta le mamme vi voglio fare una
domanda nell'ultimo minuto
qualcuno di voi ha mai sentito parlare
se ci sono degli educatori qua della
seggiolina dei pensieri i bambini e
vengono messi sulla seggiolina dei
pensieri bene due giorni fa
o forse anche se ho chiesto a un bambino
si chiama manuel ma che quando si hanno
messo della seggiovia demenziali a cosa
pensavi a spider man ma risposto
ha ragione lui cioè qui bisogna imparare
ad ascoltare tutte le persone le mamme e
bambini perché la seggiolina dei
pensieri in realtà serve agli adulti per
mettere uno spazio nel momento in cui si
prova rabbia ma al bambino non serve a
niente quindi ascoltiamo i bisogni dei
bambini ascoltiamo i bisogni degli
adulti e proviamo a comunicarli
prevediamo del tempo per la
comunicazione per il confronto del
bisogno dei sentimenti reciproci
grazie
[Applauso]